I'm making this video to respond to some ordinary gamers who shouted this out
guys, we're on the come up. Okay. We got some fake channel out in,
is out some ordinary gamers is like two mil subs, baby.
And he gave us some love.
So I wanted to respond to him because he had some interesting points.
And I want to get to that because I have a lot to say about it. He said,
look, he made a video. YouTube is promoting scams. And in his video, he's like,
Hey, there policies against promoting scams,
but it seems like YouTube is promoting them anyway. And this is my message.
I want to share with some ordinary gamers right here. Wait,
YouTube is promoting. Scams always has been.
And we're going to get into some examples into this video,
into some favoritism for advertisers over creators. I mean,
creators think where the lifeblood of this, uh, this platform, but we're not.
It's the advertisers and they get crazy preferential treatment.
Even the scammy ones we'll get into that.
But first let's go back to the office so we can talk about, um, or shout out.
Welcome back here. We have Moodle har shouting us out here.
Let's go to my, one of my favorite channels, which is coffee's Dilla. You may.
Don't worry guys. I won't let it go to my head.
I remember this channel from the time we covered the YouTube doxing situation
regarding a fellow brethren of mine, friend black.
The trend. Black's great. Make sure you go subscribe to his channel programmer.
Well, coffee's Illa somebody that focuses on a lot of these MLM scam,
CS drape D day trading scams. And, uh, he, he's a,
he's a pretty solid content creator. Give him a chance. I, I feel like, um.
This is too much. It's like watching yourself, get a compliment. It's slow,
cringy a little bit. But anyway, the point is I just, I wanted to say,
thank you.
I got a subscriber bump when he posted this a lot of love
from his community. So thank you very much.
I think we have probably have a lot of audience overlap.
He sometimes talks about scam stuff like this in the community wrongs that need
to be righted. But I wanted to say his point, which is basically,
uh, YouTube. Doesn't follow their own policies on scams.
Like how can these scams be allowed?
It seems like they're playing favorites here.
The fact that we get striked for that kind of odd,
I've literally showed you all these pyramid schemes.
They all fall under the scam section,
but how much do you think they're going to get enforced by YouTube? None.
Probably not much at all. Ladies and gentlemen,
this video is already long enough. I want it.
Anyway. That's the main point he makes.
And I wanted to add to that because a lot of you guys have not seen this clip.
I think I'm the only person on the internet.
That's seen it because otherwise all of you would be talking about it.
We actually have definitive testimony from an advertiser about the,
about the favoritism that they get. Look at this.
This is a clip from a grant Cardone podcast with Ty Lopez.
Ty Lopez at one point was one of the biggest advertisers on the platform.
That was a non-branded advertiser.
And he's to tell us just the kind of preferential treatment they get. Yeah.
But I I'm almost the biggest YouTube advertiser,
maybe Coca Cola or brand. Not that big.
That's what Google tells me of non huge brands went and compared
himself to Coca-Cola. He can't do that. Well, I'll tell you this.
Google sends two people to my house.
I got two or four reps that flight out for San Francisco. Yeah.
Uh, excuse me. You have two to four reps, dude. Hey,
I want attention all you tubers. Okay. Attention.
All you tubers.
How many of you guys have had YouTube fly out reps to your
house to make sure that everything's okay. Ty,
you're going to keep spending with us. Right? What can we do for you tie?
I mean, I don't know any other YouTube besides maybe,
maybe even Klein that gets this kind of love from the boys upstairs.
Okay. Because we just don't the rest of us creators.
You're lucky if you have a rep that will email you on the full moon of every
month. I mean, most of us don't even have that. I had a rep once,
Hey guess where they are nowhere to be found. They left the company.
I had contact for like three days with Google and then they're like, Hey,
we really value you, but we're never going to respond again.
That's the normal creator experience.
You really don't have any contact with him. And if you do, it's periodic,
it's like a telegram levels of contact. [inaudible] it's like terrible.
Nobody that I've ever seen has this level of access,
but that's what advertisers get.
So, and so I say, am I the biggest? And they go, we're not allowed to tell you,
but they wink at me. Yeah.
Yeah, of course they send those guys up.
And of course they're not going to shut down. Ty Lopez.
He's keeping the wheels turning as sick as it is. Get rich,
quick schemes, pyramid schemes. They make a lot of money.
And I want to show you, um,
the kind of crazy reasoning they use to stay within Google compliance,
okay. In their videos, they make these insane claims,
but they stay legal by making these ridiculous disclaimers all the way at the
bottom.
And I'm going to show you exactly what I mean because by if the world were just
what I'm about to show you would be considered a scam or a get rich quick
opportunity, which is technically against Google's terms of service.
Hi guys, Robby here.
And how would you like to learn how to make a thousand dollars a day online?
A thousand dollars is that online now, as a quick reminder, get rich,
quick schemes are supposedly against YouTube policies.
Remember get rich, quick schemes are against their policies.
You're not allowed to do this.
It's considered a spam deceptive practices and scams policies.
And yet this is what I got advertised on Google today.
And you could get it to you probably got one on this bit. Yeah.
In this training. And in this video,
I'm going to share with you my three-step method on how I've been able to do
that guys. So as a matter of fact,
it doesn't matter if you have any experience whatsoever. Uh,
it doesn't matter how old you are this, Hey.
You can get rich. Even if you're young, if you're like 12 years old, if you're,
you know, any age, no experience required, this is the classic.
Get rich quick scheme, a thousand dollars a day, nothing necessary right now.
You don't need anything.
Now let me show you how they get around it because there's a little,
there's an abracadabra magic words that allows you to promote scams
on YouTube. Ready? You go to his webpage. Here we go. Number one,
ClickBank affiliate in the world, free training,
how you can generate a thousand dollars a day or more.
And then you go all the way to the bottom.
Look at that all the way at the bottom. And there here's the abracadabra word.
It's so tiny. I have to go to like a thousand percent zoom to even read it.
In summary,
you understand that we make absolutely no guarantees regarding income
as a result of applying this information. Hey, are you insane?
Did you not see your own video? What does it say at the very top of this video?
What's going on guys, Robby here.
And how would you like to learn how to make a thousand dollars day online?
No assurance representation or promise regarding, uh, it doesn't matter.
How old you are. This system in this training will work for.
You guys or promise regarding future. Yeah.
And if you start following it today,
you can make a thousand dollars a day online.
We make no assurance representation or promise regarding future earnings,
new referrals and goals.
And that my friends is my response to some ordinary gamers
right here, right here. YouTube knows what they're doing.
They know what's paying the bills.
They know what's generating the revenue here.
Ty Lopez was their number one,
non like gigantic brand like Coca-Cola advertiser. Right?
These guys are paying the big bucks and that's,
what's preventing YouTube from doing a mega crackdown on YouTube.
I probably spent, I would say 25 to 30,
maybe 45 million bucks as creators. You and I, we mess up,
dude. You're lucky. If you get a strike, your channel could just get removed.
We've seen that happen.
But if a scammer says you can make a thousand dollars a day online with no
experience, no kind of training from any age. Oh, don't worry. Hey,
did you not see his fine print?
Did you not see his fine print on page seven of the income disclosure does not
click on the earnings. Disclaimer. Oops. Anyway guys,
don't I have a little heated. I'm going to be honest,
but that I wanted to make a quick response.
Not so quick response to somewhere near gamers. Thanks for the shout-out.
Thanks for the follows guys. And um, as always.
And don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.